hans ulrich jörges da kommen wir zur
these von ihnen was genau bedeutet das
für den bund was genau bedeutet das
eigentlich haben alle illegalen neue
skandale aus dem schattenreich von kona
aufgeschreckt zum einen haben wir
erfahren dass der steuerzahler um
ungefähr eine milliarde euro erleichtert
worden ist durch falsche abrechnungen
von corona testzentren privaten corona
das sind dann eine milliarde nächste
selbstbedienungs fall in diesem großen
schattenreich von corona das zweite es
sind in berlin
185000 impfstoffdosen vernichtet worden
deren
haltbarkeitsdatum überschritten war in
hamburg waren es 100.000 da frage ich
mich kann man das nicht rechtzeitig
vorher erkennen dass man sich diesem
enddatum nähert und dann diese
impfstoffe wenn sie hier nicht gebraucht
werden an länder weitergibt die sie
brauchen und sei es nordkorea die nun
zugeben dass sie ein problem haben aber
keine impfstoffe haben warum kann man
das nicht tun warum vernichtet man die
ich glaube es ist jetzt wirklich zeit
dass wir in dieser relativen ruhe die
wir jetzt haben was bewohner angeht
einen bundestags untersuchungsausschuss
einsetzen der die gesamte corona politik
der letzten zwei jahre untersucht für
mich sind alle wichtigen fragen nämlich
unbeantwortet ich habe die mal
aufgeschrieben ist sie ganz schnell vor
welche fragen das sind warum war das
gesundheitssystem nicht vorbereitet auf
die pandemie es gab mal zu einer
trockenübung vom rk ii da ist das
ergebnis sehr alarmierend in alle fächer
aller bundestagsabgeordneten gelegt
worden cmt landesregierung wurden
informiert es ist vorbei gerauscht
niemand hat es gelesen warum wurden die
alten und pflegeheime anfangs nicht
geschützt was ist kindern durch
quarantäne und schulschließungen angetan
worden was taugen masken wirklich wovor
schützen impfungen und wen gefährden sie
welche nebenwirkungen haben impfungen
wer hat die impfkampagne des bundes
gegen die wand gefahren ist die
impfpflicht mit dem grundgesetz
vereinbar durften millionen von
ungeimpften aber täglich getesteten
durch zweig vom leben ausgeschlossen
werden ist das robert-koch-institut
überfordert und schließlich wer hat sich
an corona eine goldene nase verdient und
die ergebnisse eines solchen
untersuchungsausschusses müssen wir nach
vorne gewendet werden falls es wieder
soweit kommt im herbst und winter das
ein anderes virus unterwegs ist dann
müssen schlussfolgerungen aus den
untersuchungen bezogen werden auch um
solchen wie soll ich sagen solche news
canons wie karl lauterbach ein paar
haltbaren regel in die füsse zu schlagen
frau scholz angenommen sie sind jetzt im
bundestag während dann mitglied dieses
untersuchungsausschusses
hans ulrich jörges grad nochmal mit
wirklich nachtzug ja auch gefordert hat
von dem wir eigentlich auch gehört haben
er solle kommen christian lindner hat
das ja im wahlkampf offen gesagt nun
will man in der ampelkoalition davon gar
nicht so viel wissen aber angenommen sie
saßen in diesem ausschuss und müssten zu
einem urteil kommen schlechter von aus
dem was sie an erfahrung da auch schon
mitbringt wie würde ihr urteil ausfallen
wie die maßnahmen insgesamt waren also
als wäre ich jetzt schon am ende dieser
analyse meinen sie also ich glaube dass
sehr viele maßnahmen überhaupt nicht sie
für zielführend waren dass sie
übergriffig waren dass sie
gegen ja recht geltendes recht verstoßen
haben das auch vieles vernachlässigt
wurde zum beispiel hätte man von anfang
an überhaupt erstmal daten fakten
gewinnen müssen darüber wie bedrohlich
ist denn überhaupt die situation und das
hätte man problemlos auch zu sehr
vertretbaren eurobeträgen machen können
aber man hat sich schlichtweg geweigert
das zu tun
und vieles war einfach überhaupt nicht
schlüssig widersprach jeglicher logik
und ich muss sagen da bin ich eigentlich
ehrlich gesagt auch ein gewisser weise
entsetzt in einem land wie unserem dass
das geschehen kann bei so vielen
eigentlich klugen menschen bei einem
rechtssystem wo man eigentlich denken
müsste das schützt uns vor solchen
übergriffen und dass das alles ist da
sehr ins wanken geraten also ich finde
also ich fürchte das wäre eine ganz
katastrophale bilanz thomas kaiser sie
haben ja früh vor den vor den folgen
eigentlich eines lockt downs gewarnt und
haben schon anfang 20 21 gesagt nach
dieser lockdown man sich errichtet da
aber jeder geht die wahl im zweiten
doktor auch noch mal sehr präsent mit
ihren mit ihren aussagen und haben ja
auch da gesagt dass dieser lockdown
offensichtlich unnötig und auch
verfassungswidrig ist fühlen sie sich
bestätigt es sein ich glaube das ist ein
großer fehler war ich finde alle fragen
herr jörges wie sie der aufwerfen sind
absolut relevant und sollten auch
gegenstand eines solchen
untersuchungsausschusses sein ich glaube
besonders ich bin ja nun vater von fünf
kindern und was ich wirklich
bemerkenswert fand ich meine dass man ja
klar haben wir alles in dieses die sind
zwischen 11 und 25
na ja gut aber ich mache dinge mitgehen
und eine mit 14 also erst einmal mädchen
in der pubertät wollen anfang an leben
und co absolut können auch sagen es war
ja nun von anfang an sehr sehr schnell
klar dass dieses virus extrem all das
ding ist diskriminierend unterwegs ist
und dass man keinen gedanken darauf
verschwendet hat wie man vielleicht die
gefährdeten gruppen gezielt schützen
kann und diejenigen die eigentlich
nichts zu befürchten haben so normal wie
möglich leben lassen weiterleben lassen
kann das glaube ich es in der tat da
haben wir uns an den kindern wirklich
versündigt ich habe hier mal einfach das
gedankenexperiment in den raum gestellt
was denn gewesen wäre wenn es genau
umgekehrt gewesen wäre wenn nur die
jungen betroffen gewesen wären dann
hätte man wahrscheinlich den industrie
club in düsseldorf nicht geschlossen
haben schulen dass man alle haben das
war nicht in ordnung war man hat diesen
forderungen bzw auch mit diesen aussagen
die getätigt haben im locker und 2020 im
doktor 29 eigentlich in ihrer partei und
gerade auch bei karl lauterbach gar kein
gehör geschenkt und also ich sage mal
morgens sagen die der zeitgeist war in
der tat anders es war eine allgemeine
panik was mich auch überrascht weil er
manchmal den eindruck die politik
vermittelt den eindruck der staat habe
quasi eine garantenpflicht dafür
übernommen dass niemand mehr krank wird
ich habe immer gesagt ein bisschen
eigenverantwortung insbesondere wenn
impfstoff da ist und genügend impfstoff
dass jeder davon gebrauch machen kann
und wenn jeder die regeln kennt mit
denen er sich schützen kann also diese
regeln dann bin ich schon der meinung
dann muss der staat eigentlich nicht
weiter tätig sein dann muss man oder
muss man jedenfalls verhalten und
beschränkungen regeln den regelungen
massiv zurückfahren dann kann man ein
stück weit jedenfalls solange das
gesundheitswesen nicht insgesamt
gefährdet ist und ich glaube auch dass
wir immer gegenstand einer solchen der
suche nach meiner kenntnis
auch wenn es immer wieder an die wand
gemalt wurde war das gesundheitswesen in
wahrheit nie gefährden wir hatten als
ich noch oberbürgermeisterwahl in
düsseldorf jeden tag die
wasserstandsmeldungen über freie
kapazitäten frei intensivmedizinische
kapazitäten in den krankenhäusern der
war nie auch nur wie soll man sagen
entfernt irgendein notstand so dass man
sagen muss also die gefahr bestand nicht
und das blieb nach meinem dafürhalten
praktisch unberührt hat sich verzogen
hatte nachdem auch gerade was thomas
kaiser gesagt hat sich eigentlich aus
ihrer sicht und das ist glaube ich für
einen liberalen immer dann ein moment wo
man noch mal innehalten muss hat sich
aus ihrer sicht eigentlich der anspruch
der bundesbürger nach dieser panini an
den start noch mal wieder verstärkt also
dieser fürsorge des staates dieser start
der meinte alles regeln zu müssen bis
ins mikro detail eigentlich die hatten
ja nur zwei jahre begleitet und viele
fanden das ja irgendwie gar nicht so
schlecht glauben sie dass das
nachwirkende folgen hat das das
bleibende schäden hinterlässt also es
gibt den schönen satz das problem des
liberalismus in deutschland ist dass
menschen mit ihrer freiheit oftmals
nicht so viel anzufangen wissen da merkt
man das gilt in der tat nach wie vor
auch bei vielen menschen gerade dann
wenn sie eben halt nicht richtig
informiert werden ich bin nicht der
auffassung dass ist und zwar anders noch
mal es entspricht dem leitbild des
grundgesetzes dass ich selbst darüber
bestimmen wie ich leben möchte das ist
genau die lehre die der parlamentarische
rat gezogen hat als bruch als das klare
bild was wir eigentlich als die neuen
staatsbürger wollten nicht mehr der
staat der sich um dich kümmert sondern
du selbst der duh teilnimmst an diesen
demokratischen staatswesen dir selbst
eine meinung bildet dich selbst
einbringt und so weiter und so fort das
ist unterschiedlich so dumm geführt
worden in der partie ist komplett
umgedreht worden genau uns war nicht
passt kümmern sondern absolut
übergriffig denn es geht ein staatswesen
im übrigen eines des so versagt hat wie
dieses überhaupt nichts an ob ich krank
werde oder nicht es ist meine sache wie
ich leben möchte und wenn nicht barfuß
durch den schnee laufen will und mir
dann lungenentzündung holen dann ist das
meine freie entscheidung ist mein
problem ist wieder ziemlich doof aber es
ist mein körper das ist meine sache und
wir haben hier erlebt dass ein staat und
das ist doch der der witz an der sache
dass ein staat der ein staatliches
gesundheitswesen propagiert der sich
darum kümmert der dafür steuern
einsammelt um dieses gesundheitswesen
hin zu stellen sagt ach mensch wir haben
nicht genug vorgesorgt wir sind nicht
leistungsfähig genug und weil wir nicht
leistungsfähig genug sind weil wir das
geld für andere sachen ausgegeben haben
kriegst du jetzt zusätzlich noch einen
finanziellen schaden oder im übrigen
auch einen gesundheitlichen schaden
infolge der lock down und den trägst du
auch noch dass das ist pervers das ist
das gegenteil des staatsverständnis ist
dass die vielen väter und wenigen mittel
des grundgesetzes hatten das ist das ist
das kernproblem und wir sind jetzt immer
noch nicht dabei dafür tatsächlich mal
evaluieren was an schäden angerichtet
wurde durch den ganzen irakischen kraft
und warum das geschehen ist ich habe als
abgeordneter seiner zeit immer wieder
versucht die vorlagen zu bekommen mit
denen der senat auf seine tollen
verordnungsebene kamen ja warum das
gefährlich sein soll in ein auto
geschäft zu gehen aber nicht gefährlich
im fahrradladen und sonstige unfug so
der habe ich nie bekommen man hat sich
einfach der demokratischen kontrolle
entzogen ich mich hat er an und zwar
dauerhaft erschüttert die erfahrung
dieser pandemie
dass die übergroße mehrheit der menschen
ohne sich zu rühren zugesehen hat wie
die nicht geimpften diskriminiert und
vom leben ausgeschlossen worden sind und
zwar über lange zeit obwohl sie sich für
den beruf für das büro oder da wo sie
gearbeitet haben die werkstatt täglich
haben testen lassen müssen die waren im
prinzip
nachgewiesen gesünder als diejenigen die
vor einem viertel oder halben jahr
geimpft worden sind und nicht mehr
untersucht worden sind aber man hat sie
ausgeschlossen
und das hat niemanden irritierte als
auch niemand aufgestanden hat gesagt so
geht das nicht ganz wenige ich wir haben
hier immer dazugehört ich habe auch dazu
gehört aber das war völlig irrelevant
und das hat mir gezeigt dass in dieser
gesellschaft
ich sage jetzt mal fast alles wieder
möglich ist aber ich glaube man genau
das wäre es nämlich ein faktor den man
glaube ich wirklich nicht unterschätzen
darf ist massenpsychologie und zwar also
ich will überhaupt jetzt nicht sagen
dass es so gewesen ist aber wenn jemand
es inszeniert hätte hätte er es nicht
besser tun können wo kommt diese gehen
hin her als wir deutschen offenbar ja
ist das toll finden wenn man dann unser
angst
hätten gerne regeln ob sie sinnvoll sind
oder nicht
aber es ist weit verbreitet und sehe ich
das tollste war in dem düsseldorfer
brauhaus da sitzen sie einem tisch ohne
maske natürlich trinken bier und lachen
und sobald sie sich auf den einsamen weg
auf die toilette begeben müssen sind
wasser aufsetzen das ist nun
offensichtlich keine sinnvolle regeln
und trotzdem wollte sie durchgesetzt und
trotzdem man sich alle dran gehalten
also ein stück weit das war nicht die
allgemeine verunsicherung auch aber da
braucht man welt so was wie orientierung
aber einmal zu hinterfragen macht es
wirklich sinn wer glaub ich schaue aber
hat die politik daraus gelernt jetzt so
da hat ein politiker haus nicht gelernt
auch gerade mit blick auf das was wir
heute wieder gehört haben vom
gesundheitsminister und was
möglicherweise in den nächsten wochen
noch kommt also ob die politik daraus
gelernt hat das möchte ich sehr
bezweifeln also ich glaube auch dass die
personen die dazu beigetragen haben
panik zu machen zu machen natürlich
jetzt schlecht wagen können da haben wir
wohl fehler gemacht weil damit
diskreditieren sie sich selbst auf
gewisse art aber vielleicht noch mal
zurück zu diesem thema also ich glaube
man darf nicht unterschätzen die
massenpsychologie da stattgefunden hat
das am anfang war immer die rede von dem
neuartigen neuartigen virus wo man
dachte da kommt jetzt das monster wir es
aus asien dank kursierten irgendwelche
videos wohl menschen plötzlich auf der
straße umfallen in china und dann ich
glaube das war ganz entscheiden kann die
bilder aus bergamo und da wurde
sozusagen wenn man jetzt mal den
menschen wirklich als tier betrachtet da
wurde das system nämlich die amygdala
sowas von aktiviert horror schrecklich
särge die sich stapeln und da gibt da
kommt man auch irgendwann gar nicht mehr
mit fakten dagegen an um einfach mal zu
sagen in italien wird normalerweise
werden finden keine
feuerbestattung statt und da war auf
einmal eine neue vorschrift eingeführt
worden die krematorien war nicht darauf
vorbereitet und auf einmal stapeln sich
natürlich die sage aber da sitzt die
angst schon im knochen bricht in jeder
faser des körpers und ich glaube da das
da sozusagen alle erfasst wurden von von
einem jahr von den botschaften die
stellen die ständig auf sie
einprasselten und vor allem die bilder
ich glaube die bilder haben sozusagen
den den nährboden dafür bereitet dass
man nachher dann nur noch dachte
hoffentlich werden leute wie herr wie la
vie ersparen wissen was sie tun das sind
ja die experten gut dass ich die
entscheidung nicht treffen muss und dann
hat man sich ergeben man hat sich
sozusagen ergeben und hat versucht sich
möglichst gut durch zu manövrieren durch
die maßnahmen